turning now to the war in Ukraine and
Ukrainian militaries conducting drills
near the border with Belarus to protect
against any new Russian invasion from
the north this comes as America's top
Diplomat met briefly with Russia's
foreign minister to demand an end to the
war MTS tire is near the Belarusian
border
in their first meeting since the war in
Ukraine began over a year ago Secretary
of State Anthony blinken's message to
his Russian counterpart was clear and
this war of aggression
engage in meaningful diplomacy that can
produce a just and durable peace
but until there is a lasting peace
Ukrainian forces aren't taking any
chances
these drills on the Northern front
follow warnings the Kremlin is planning
a renewed offensive in the spring
this Maze of trenches was built after
Russian forces crossed over here from
Belarus as part of their failed push
towards Kiev last February says this
Ukrainian Commander if Russian forces
move over this border
are you ready for them
yes and we've prepared a lot of presents
for them he says with a wise smile
these trenches could be straight out of
world war one but make no mistake these
men have modern technology at their
fingertips
another Soldier demonstrates a
reconnaissance drone used to scour the
skies and Border for any signs of
trouble so this is inside Belarus
but in Ukraine's East the fighting is
only intensifying with the town of
bakmut now nearly all under Russia's
control making protecting the north an
even higher priority for CBS mornings
I'm India's taib on the Ukrainian
Belarusian border